you
everyone is Jerry I'm on just calm and I
just got paired up playing a 300 game so
initially I wanted a 5 oh but here we
are with a 3 oh no increments so we're
going to prepare to tuck the bishop away
in h2 and yeah we could have a bit of a
race position coming up I want to
recapture with the pond
so what raise position am I talking
about c4 or castle and goeth castle
first let's see if they resolve this
tension okay let's get on with it c4
Knight c3 I'm defending my bishop so
still I can take on take stakes 94 I
have Knight d5 b4 and c6 or excuse me B
4 C 5 let's just get a quick move in
there I'm still curious what uh what's
gonna do with this tension okay let's
play Queen here this is preparing b4 at
some stage I'll shut it down now that
the bishop is committed here we'll eat
4b plate or not if not I have e4 I'm
gonna go for it my queen isn't feeling
so comfortable here anymore
okay so Knight v6 my bishops a bit out
of play
I feel like I need to reposition this
night let's maybe head for the be
Foursquare get out of this pin could be
a sacrifice here no it happens it
happens not too much I could really do
about that I have to defend here and
watch out for night b3 covering a 493
this is a strong piece I want to
challenge it
given time I have Bishop g3 into age
five he needs to do something else it's
a strong move heading for the weak point
in my position could still like to
challenge this guy he will be tough to
get rid of though must be said let's
start with tonight f3 most invasive
piece for me is this guy right here and
I should probably challenge him further
I guess they're lining up Bishop g5 okay
and now Bishop there it's good move okay
let's get my knight doing something else
get back over here I want to trade off
this bishop somehow it's going to be
difficult to do
I'll try for Bishop to eat - it's
awkward to go into this pin but yeah
thought you might do that
pulling very fast and let's go here
maybe Bishop f1 and then g3 didn't
really see that move coming
all right they were threatening made on
g2 I doubt they'd go with repetition
Knight f4 bishop f1 there's a knight
takes h3 ok where are the tactics ain't
tactics here let's drop the bishop back
my queen is opposite their king Bishop
takes pawn followed by a pawn push might
be something um I'm really tempted to
just do that
let's break over here though this
bishops unprotected 45 seconds this is a
soft point
I'll take with the bishop be careful of
g2 hitting the bishop now think I have
everything defended let's get really
active with the Queen when you take
spawn here I'm on the rook there might
be a push here
it's tense
could I
and then play g3 I think so I with the
sack
oh this is this is uh you know I think
they have to try for that I'll tuck my
King in the corner though no evening out
on the clock let's hop her Queen
exchange let's go here
okay they're moving fast still
you
my queen is very misplaced yeah I think
I have everything covered over here
still have everything covered
not sure what that's doing tough to find
a good move here
okay
we have to I'm getting chased around
there night is fantastic they could get
the exchange back eight point six
seconds
okay they're giving me the dark squares
cleany three
check
Bishop g5 in
ah
and a lot of time
got to do time burners
that's what it's come down to Oh No
oh my goodness they're down on time Wow
oh man what an ugly ugly end for a three
oh game
messy messy messy messy messy
um I should probably have automatic
clean on I didn't want to have to select
a piece to promote to
oh man I was under some heavy heavy fire
now you that's tough adjustment going
from five oh two or three oh man that
was an ugly end but let's have a look at
that middle game actually before I go
into the analysis
you know I don't know maybe this is this
is my first thought is when I played a3
was this really necessary it struck me
as a little bit awkward to see a6
usually by right around this point in
fact instead of committing the rook to
e8
black I'll already commit pushing here
and then it's just a big race where you
know well you could still see this where
I'm heading on the queenside I'm looking
for this kind of play and black is
looking for this kind of stuff
sacrifices over here and such but the
tension was maintained so that struck me
mmm I don't know I I saw that this was a
little bit different so I'm questioning
whether or not I should have played H or
a a3 but I've done something a bit more
useful mm-hmm let me bring up the
analysis okay so let's just kill the
engine for a moment this is the board I
want so I'm white could I've done
something other than a3 is the first
question I have for myself
so right here right when I saw something
I wasn't familiar with I went with a
three hmm what could I do that's more
productive Queen c2 maybe
huh well how did it play out in the game
when I played Queen c2 eventually we had
a big structure shift and my queen was
exposed along the C file hmm I think I
think 83 is okay it's a pretty useful
move it's not committing the Queen just
yet and maybe I could do without Queen
c2 in this game yeah after a three if I
said a three why not go it's before yeah
I don't think I should commit my queen
just yet
b4 I think would save me a lot of
trouble and then on Bishop d7 maybe then
I could consider d5 yeah maybe something
like this is an improvement in fact what
might be a better square for my queen is
b3 instead of c2 so once I get in a 3
and B 4 I think I like the Queen post
here the B file I don't think is going
to open up or it can't open up as
quickly black cannot force open the B
file let's just say black and force open
the C file with the c6 push but not the
B file so I think my Queen would be a
little bit more comfortable I'm looking
into this because I waste a lot of time
with my Queen went to see to got out of
the pin she was she ran a marathon in
this game really and she was kind of
struggling to find a target opponent had
all their bass points covered and even
though I was up the exchange they had an
attack against my king as you saw
okay so I went with Queen c2 I think I
think right around this point we can put
on the engine
let's just have a quick look through the
beginning no just checking for blunders
here there's nothing nothing missed for
Idris either side something close to
equal get in c4 and then c3 let's see
with Bishop g3 I didn't touch on this
but the reason I went to h2 instead of
g3 is that sometimes there can be a
quick 94 and so I wouldn't want that to
strike at my bishop so 83 no issues I
guess you could play a lot of different
things here but once you go with the d5
right now though I think I would still
play how I did in the game
meaning wait for the bishop to
fianchetto and then slammed the door
make sure he's pulled off of this
because if it's gonna close down in the
center the direction black would want to
go in is with f5 and the bishop would no
longer be there supporting a5 so if I'm
gonna play d5 I want to wait for the
bishop to commit it's the short story
clean C to d5 now I guess I could have
considered capturing huh I just went
with efore maybe I'm in a fine position
to take and then throw a rock on the D
file okay
as an alternative I was just playing
against the bishop with this move just
want to reinforce the d5 point but now
my queen is a little bit awkward b5 yeah
this Knight is a pretty big pest nice c5
Knight b6 the d4 I should say the c4 and
c5 squares our nice posts for the
Knights yeah
he's a bit off out of play I would in
this structure I would really like to
have the bishop here where he's
contributing on the queenside and he's
not just staring at this pawn here I
don't think I'm ever in a position to
try and play for f4 there's a lot of
action happening on the Queen side at
this stage so I do some repositioning
here what is it suggesting he wants to
get the bishop right into the ball game
I might as well regard the bishop on h2
as if he's still on the back ranked
undeveloped so I mean it's it's a little
bit long-winded but maybe I could pin
maybe I could think about getting to e3
one day it just takes forever to do that
but yeah he's way out of play and I
don't think I'm in a good position to
deal with this changing of the structure
so black has the as an edge here
you know I thought even right around
this point there's an exchange sacrifice
it should be something close to equal
well more than that just likes this yeah
rook takes Knight that's what the
computer wants to go for here I thought
that that was a possibility because it's
more than just a pawn I think this one's
going to be tracked down soon because
they could just hammer away at it
Queen c2 there's a temple against my
queen but going here adding another
piece on this I'm never gonna be able to
defend that so they had that opportunity
to give up the rook for Knight and grab
a couple pawns and doesn't get any more
well those are two pretty important
pawns to Center pawns on top of it yeah
I'm worse we need three they did some
fancy Knight moves let's see if there
any killer shots missed number one
priority try and get rid of that guy so
I'm heading for Knight f3 in 92
I'd have 392
takes takes yeah
Bishop g5 g3 I thought about G thread
invoicing in the game it looks really
weird to do that to your bishop but and
at least it at least stops the minor
pieces from pivoting on f4 okay I'm
wondering once it did turn better
forming how I could have converted it
that doubled on the only open file fell
really awkward to do that but felt like
I need to transfer my queen b3 wants to
take out the bishop I would have been
fine with that I see this night as super
valuable in my position f4 is really
strong square this is my bad bishop
okay didn't go for that opening up a new
square for the Queen on g5 I just want
to tuck my bishop back on f1 here but I
can't do that right now
because that would run into the night
takes h3 dropping one pawn and another
in the exchange so wants to take out the
night I played Bishop g3 I wasn't so
quick to give up my number one Bishop
computer seems to always be suggesting
Knight takes bishop but wasn't happening
and Knight f4 rook b8 ooh that's a
really weird move to make rook to b8
maybe right around this point I turn
better yeah
I take firsts I guess I could have held
my ground with capturing yeah you know I
come to think of it with this exchange
of my epon for what what happened there
upon is exchanged I could highlight I
don't know why I wasn't highlighting the
whole way the epon can be it was
exchanged for the G pond and there was a
lot of heat thrown at my king so I
should probably hold this tension and
get on with a for right now that would
have been an improvement in this
position of course right around this
point I think it's bullet mount for both
of us I take and then play a four I
thought at least Wednesday for coming
soon they'd have six a for now all right
I pick up a pond and it wants to take
with the night the night why didn't I go
at the night I was afraid of dropping
this pawn because as it is right now I
have three each of us has three pieces
on it
so that's why I took with the bishop I
guess the other way to look at it is
that I'm taking a pond and I'm striking
it now a weak point maybe even Knight f7
one day I give this guy up but maybe
that's not so bad if the position maybe
I you know given more time of course
some thought process that kind of better
influenced my play here was yeah let's
just go pond for pond let's just open it
up more and more because I have the
safer King to put three pawns you just
have one more pawns exchanged more files
are open more diagonals but yeah I
didn't and how the time to really think
that one through obviously you know I'm
feeling the pressure against my king
okay I've done different with my queen
yeah it's really tough to get ok so
there's something here Knight b5 now
striking it d6 what did I do
I played that in there with my queen I
guess that's ok as well now they give up
that this is +2 so right around here
what could I have done better tough to
find something with the time pressure
I just instinctually just dropped back
here wants to take the knight huh
take the knight and then take on d6 and
this is this is very easy actually
because when this pawn drops this piece
that was terrible is now probably one of
my best pieces it's ready to sweep into
e5 whit's check yeah that would crumble
really fast mm-hmm it should have ran
through my mind he just gives some
material back I'm off the exchange at
this point rook takes Knight he's a
strong piece he's in my house get rid of
him and then crashed through on d6 and
there shouldn't be a way for black to
hold that together
I go for the Queen exchange and okay
still just a nibble better but that
night is what a pest it's tough to get
at this base point now my rooks are not
really doing anything king h1 anything
else missed let's go with the f3 right
now
yeah now they're better
let's Bishop to d3 oooh undermining my
defender g2 yeah a lot of stuff will be
missed anything else yeah I guess nuts
yeah it's just bullet mode at this point
and Queen f2 we're still holding some I
still have something here I have to get
my roots doing something though I don't
feel like any of my pieces are
productive in this position Bishop to b5
rook c8 and then rip to E - no no no
quick way to mobilize the pieces I felt
like I had to do this get a rock on the
seventh giving up the exchange now
giving it up giving it back and I could
just take on f4 right now instead of
capturing first doesn't have to worry
about this night giving a bunch of
checks it's still better for me and I
think I had I don't know eight seconds
here - a little time and this was just a
complete blur I don't want to look at
this I was just trying to click on the
Queen when I promoted there I have to
change that in my settings but what a
wild finish I had point two on that one
interesting game again I'd be thinking
more about b4 before Queen c2
I should also look more into simply
capturing in this position and changing
the structure playing over here and also
mobilizing my bishop a lot faster than I
did in the game just some quick points
with this three Oh time control not my
favorite time control prefer 3:2 over
anything really prefer 3:2 even over the
five Oh time can
three-oh was for in this game as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
wild game wild finish in the comments
section below
and I hope you got something of it
that's all for now take care bye
you
[Music]